the jurogan experience well i caught
camaro usman a vet
yeah i know i mean for sure in the
gilbert burns fight that was veteran
[ __ ]
when he just weathered that storm in
that first round and by the end of the
first round was winning
yeah you know and then [ __ ] him up in
the second and his striking's getting
better
oh my god is getting better that fight
this weekend is
very interesting you know i watched the
first fight again the other day
yeah and i'm gonna tell you something
man maz vidal was all over him in that
first round
and that was last minute correct six
days notice
he stuffed what 11 of his takedowns
which is unheard of with his men
yeah but more importantly was not in
condition
no was not prepared for a fight like
that they offered it to him
he took it he went there six days notice
and i'm
i mean that first round he looked very
good
he only won that one round yeah that's
one that's what's important in the fight
because usman made adjustments another
thing that's important to note is that
usman apparently
had shattered his nose two weeks before
that fight wow yeah so his nose is
[ __ ]
because after the fight you know they
they you know had him checked out he had
a broken nose
and he was like my nose is already
broken like his nose is [ __ ] up two
weeks before the fight
yeah the thing about uzman man is that
he he
some people say he's boring you know
boring fighter
i think he's great i think he's a great
wasn't boring that gilbert bernstein oh
no he wasn't
i think he's great man he's he presses
the fight he's got cardio for days
and a guy that looks has that kind of
physique i know he shouldn't have that
kind of cardio
and he's got he's just i think he's
great i think he's got charisma man
his striking's getting better he
freaking knocked out
colby covington tko and broke his jaw
and that he
burns with a jab anybody who says he's
boring is an idiot
you get poked in the eye just poke
yourself in the eye
i mean you got to be an idiot to think
that guy's boring
that's crazy look he did what he had to
do to win the mas vidal fight but if you
take any consideration the fact that he
had a broken nose
going into the fight and you taking into
consideration the fact that maz vidal is
you know you fought him he's game good
he's game
and he's clever and he's experienced and
he's a real vet
yeah is a real vet that's that that's a
somebody that
who you cannot break this guy's will in
a fight no
i've seen it i've broken guys wills and
in there in the fight when a guy like
that
who comes out just as hard in the last
round as he does in the first
and still has got power and still is
just just a savage just
just want to rip your head off that's a
scary dude but you hit him he just like
he smiles at you
yeah and normally when guys do that
they're hurt
right but this guy you know that's just
he's just a g man
he's slick and i like him because he's
he is who he is he is really faking
nobody he's not trying to be somebody
he's not
i love when he dresses like tony montana
he's got the the whole suit get up when
i talk to him here one of my favorite
moments on the podcast with him here was
when uh
i asked him i said well i go the
question is uh can
ben ask her and get a hold of you he
goes he can get a hold of these nuts
dude that guy boy that's why i love i
love that guy and
it was funny i was in singapore me and
him both were there for as gas fighters
and that's what that's where we made
that fight happen
oh we had planned it out there he was
wanting to work his way up and i just
lost the tire and so
the second time so i was let's make it
happen man
and uh he's i think what's changed
from him i wouldn't say so much his
style but his mindset
hmm yeah he talked about that the
resurrection
yeah well you know when it happened he
went on a reality show do you know the
story
i i think so yeah and
did it was it the preparation or was it
no he talked about that on this podcast
too
he went on this reality show and it was
a [ __ ] nightmare and he was it was
like in the jungle
in this reality show like he had to like
go into villages trying to get food
it was [ __ ] it's crazy it was a south
american reality show
and apparently he was there for a long
ass time and he had no contact with the
outside world it was a disaster
hated the show but it gave him a lot of
chance to think about his life
about where he was and then what his
future is going to be
and realize that maybe some things have
been holding him back
yeah one thing that had been holding him
back was he was trying not to lose
versus trying to win and that he was a
little bit worried about his condition
because maybe he didn't train
enough maybe he didn't prepare correctly
and then he just decided
look i'm going to [ __ ] go for it yeah
so here he is
i mean maz vidal's got to be your age
right he's probably 38.
he's in the range i think he's a little
bit you might be a little bit younger 36
something like that but one of the most
popular guys in the ufc said he was
going to do it
he's there yeah fight for the title
twice but just think about what he did
after that think about his fight
like the fight with nate diaz holy [ __ ]
how the knockout of terran till yeah the
darren till knockout was [ __ ]
crazy and he him getting knocked down
early in that fight he got knocked down
comes back
oh my goodness yeah and and ko'd him in
the most
vicious fashion and and the way he did
it too where he set it up that switch
where he stepped in and throws the left
hook
well he grabbed his front hand i don't
know if you saw that mm-hmm he grabbed
his front hand pulls it down and hits it
with a left yep
yeah that's what oh so so smooth
so well he's so clever he's clever
like the knockout of ben askren like
people think oh he just
ran at him and threw a flying knee no no
no no
he went to the side yeah and then he
came out angle changed man
he went at him also so aspirin has to
follow him
which even more activates ascerin's
natural desire to grab you yeah
right i mean he showed him planning for
it and he went to the side we're asking
asprin shoots
yeah i mean he went to the side and then
boom
the whole lead-up to that was awesome oh
my god him just
incredible yeah you know just looking
like a freaking g
and then he steps off and that photo of
him
in midair landing that knee to ben's
face
jack you see us oh yeah angry look in
his face
that's one of the classic all-time mma
photos
see if you can find that photo and then
him saying was that necessary to hit him
super necessarily this is super
necessary yeah super necessary well not
only that he he like as
ben is out cold after he punches he's
talking to him and slapping the table
like i told you [ __ ]
yeah crazy and what's good about him is
that he can he can throw something like
obviously
there it is wow that's that one in the
middle is the one i'm talking about the
one up yeah look at that
that is a [ __ ] classic mma
in the middle the middle of the [ __ ]
impact look at his face he's so angry
that was damn i was there too
i was there saying casey anyone after
that fight i went up and congratulated
him he was like man
say thank you bro i was like we need to
make this fight have we need to do it
again
that was crazy [ __ ] he became a
superstar that night that's right
been at the two knockouts crazy
knockouts back to back yep
and now he has another chance at usman
with a full camp
super interested on paper it's like
all right how do you choose against
somebody who's been so dominant in the
welterweight division again
oozman but then you get this guy out
there who can just
out of nowhere just do out of you know a
thought in his head
he would spin something or a flying knee
or he's so
creative and i'm interested intelligent
i would never count usman out i think
usman is one of those
mentally he's one of the strongest guys
that have ever seen compete
his mind you just you never see a
weakness from him you know he's just
he's so strong and when he dominated
tyron like that to win the belt
it's his first shot at the title no
nerves at all just full
dominance just went at him just
controlled him smashed him just beat him
up
almost tried to take him out at one
point in time and emptied the gas tank
and realized like jesus tyron's still
here
and we talked about it on the podcast to
him like how tired he where he's like
bro
i was so tired he didn't show it he
didn't show i could see it a little bit
but i was right next to him you know i
was right there watching it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience